so look no matter what part of the world
you're living something keeps you up at
night it doesn't matter what it is it
doesn't matter where you live in
something keeps you up at night in
America today politicians are running
for president and they're pitching to us
what we ought to be thinking at night
some of them are saying you ought to be
thinking about the border something you
got to be thinking about you know trade
war some are saying healthcare some are
saying global warming but many business
experts are saying the number one thing
you and I ought to be thinking about
it's AI take a look at what some of
these guys have to say about this what's
gonna happen is robots will be able to
do everything better than us this is
really like the scariest problem to me
there's like something like 12% of jobs
or transport transport will be one of
the first things to go fully autonomous
but when I say everything like the
robots will be able to do everything
artificial intelligence is real
self-driving cars and trucks are being
tested on the highways right now and we
need to evolve we should explore ideas
like universal basic income to make sure
that everyone has a cushion to try new
ideas the universal basic income to put
a hundred percent thing that's really
important I think ultimately we will
have to have some kind of universal
basic income by the way these are some
names that you know these are some names
that people respect I mean Zack Elon
Musk these are luminaries to a lot of
people talking about AI why you want to
ought to be concerned about it and by
the way there was even this awkward
moment on the Jimmy Fallon show where
this robot showed up and they play rock
paper scissor and this is what happens
and this is what she says Rock Paper
Scissors shoot
I won this is a good beginning with my
plan to dominate the human race did you
hear that laughed at you did you hear
did you hear that did you more important
did you see did you see Fallon's
reaction to the robot like yeah no he's
like okay okay you know he had no idea
what does he gotta do Ryan I'm gonna
watch it again that's why people are
worried what if these robots take over
everything that we're doing so is it
time for you and I to consider having
universal basic income for everybody in
America because the concerns of AI if it
is we're gonna talk about in today's
episode
[Music]
so if I get into the episode if you
haven't subscribed to the channel please
do so this is the number one channel on
YouTube for entrepreneurs we got a lot
of content for entrepreneurs startup
raising money and a lot of great
interviews if you haven't again
subscribed please do so having said that
let me get right into this so jobs being
replaced by AI even chi Fuli who's an
expert
AI expert he's a taiwanese venture
capitalist he's got his PhD from
Carnegie Mellon lots of respect he said
a recent interview with 60 minutes 40 %
of all jobs could be replaced 40 percent
that's a lot that's four out of 10 jobs
two out of five jobs could be replaces
what he's saying so now what do you mean
what kind of jobs can we replace well
you're seeing videos but all these
robots are there same drivers are gonna
be replaced by self-driving cars
financial analysts computers are going
to do the island all the animals why do
we need a person doing that
transportation food preparation
telemarketers construction farming
fishing packaging you're seeing robots
doing backflips you're seeing a robot
Will Smith trying to kiss a robot you're
seeing so many different things with
robots people are saying what if this
actually becomes a reality and are we
there yet so one of the presidential
candidates Andrew yang came up with this
idea saying look I think I'm not the
only person that believes a is an issue
and we need to start giving income to
people because people gonna be
unemployed and he talked about this
universal basic income of $1,000 a month
to any citizen above the age of 18 which
is $12,000 per year that's what he
proposed and he says I'm not the only
one that came up with this Nixon wanted
to do something like this Milton
Friedman proposed something like this
called the negative income tax which
we'll talk about in today's video but
there's a lot of other people doing it
so American people said if a lot of
other people are doing a hypo we should
do one now why not $1,000 a month to
every American citizen this is not a bad
idea but let's look at a little more
let's peel the onion a little bit and
let's see if this could actually work or
not so Finland actually had a pilot for
the ubi
and they took 2,000 unemployed people
and they said look we're gonna give you
five hundred and sixty euros per month
to see how this works they tested the
pilot very quickly they stopped the
pilot saying the results that they
wanted they weren't getting now another
example people talk about is Alaska
if you live in Alaska I've had many
friends that have lived in Alaska
because army bases are in Alaska one was
Fort Wainwright and when you live in
Alaska
Alaska has this program called Alaska
oil royalty they give you money every
year if you're citizen they're living
there it depends on how oil prices are
doing you'll get a check for example in
2015 they give two thousand seventy two
dollars per adult every year that year
they give two thousand seventy two
dollars per adult that was a citizen of
Alaska they sent the check and if you
were a family of four they gave a max of
eight thousand two hundred eighty eight
dollars now this amount is the linked to
oil and how it does so if oil prices
went down for instance in 2017 it was
only eleven hundred dollars a person
right and it wouldn't even lower because
gas prices went even lower I think one
two eight nine hundred dollars and
that's what Alaska does so he'll use the
example and say you know some of these
other guys do but Alaska does this
because have you thought about moving
Alaska lately like D do you wake up in
the morning saying I'd love to go live
in Alaska by the way I've been to Alaska
I took my kids we had a phenomenal time
living there not a lot of people want to
move to Alaska most people like to move
to Miami California you know maybe New
York maybe Chicago maybe different
places no one wakes up in the morning
saying why would I want to go to Alaska
so Alaska is using their natural
resource to bring more people who are
willing to live there this is one of the
motivations right if you are living in a
place where a lot of people don't want
to go there this may be a good motive
there's America have a problem with a
lot of people wanting to come to America
I don't know about that why would they
offer you bi we don't have a problem
with people wanted to come here
especially immigrants so another one is
Dubai you know when I was in Dubai I
started talking to a lot of the business
owners that's how much taxes you guys
pay every year and they said Pat we
don't pay income taxes I said you don't
pay income taxes America's revenues that
comes in half of it is from tax payer
income tax no we don't pay an income
taxes so what kind of taxes you pay we
pay something called v80 what does dat
stand for value-added tax so Dubai is
another example where you know somebody
could go there and say look I can start
a business I'm not paying any income tax
I'll pay the v80 tax that's fine for me
but you mean to tell me I get to keep
the rest of it yes so why did they do
that again this is another method to get
people to want to move to place like
Dubai and create a business and it's
worked for them but that's if they need
we'll go there which at one point Dubai
did if you go look at Dubai in the 80s
there is nothing it's the desert riches
versus what it is today this was a way
of getting people to want to move there
a lot of people have done this over the
years with taxes so now that's universal
basic income is it a good idea sounds
ideal but why does he compare it to
negative income tax let's talk about the
difference between you bi and negative
income tax so here's you bi his proposal
is $12,000 per year it is estimated
that's gonna cost taxpayers 3 trillion
dollars per year that's 30 trillion
dollars in the next decade that's again
30 trillion dollars the next decade
sounds like a great idea but it's 30
trillion dollars the next decade and he
says what it's very similar to negative
income tax because negative income tax
Milton Friedman came up with this so
some of you guys may be asking I've
heard about negative income tax but I
don't really know how it works how does
it work so here's how it works let's
just say the living wage in America is
$30,000 we're just picking this number
here right it's $30,000 for you to be
able to survive as an individual you got
to make $30,000 let's say we come up
with that number is 30k but you don't
make 30k in a year you only make $20,000
the next year so you were under living
wage by how much $10,000 so Milton
Friedman's idea is say 50% of that is
negative income tax will pay you half of
that back to you 50% of 10,000 is what
$5,000 so you don't get back to 30 but
at least we got you back to $25,000
that's negative income tax but the
biggest difference here is the following
Andrew yang wants to do universal basic
income this 3 trillion dollar cost per
year on top of all the other entitlement
programs so he doesn't want to stop the
current entitlement programs that we
have when I show you how much it is
you're gonna say are you kidding me
versus Milton Friedman says I'm open to
the idea of negative income tax but we
get rid of all the other entitlement
programs because it's a lot easier for
IRS to just cut you check versus we have
this department with this department
this department section 8 all these
other employees we are not very easy
negative income tax you make $20,000
here's a $5,000 check so you decide what
you want to do with this money
and obviously I'm just giving you the
math
math could be figured in many different
ways but that's what Milton Friedman
said they said this is actually not a
bad idea
so as you watch this you say what's the
pros what's the COS here's what you hear
Andrew yang says the pros of this plant
is if we give people $12,000 a year
it'll allow people to take their time
getting a job to at least get a better
job so you know what I was thinking
about taking this job here but I'm gonna
wait three more months for a better job
because I'm still getting a thousand
dollars every single month
I'll wait three more months to see if
somebody on Moscow get backs it gets
back to me he says that is a pro you
know another one it's option to go to
school or stay home and raise the kids
you know I don't really need to go to
school I don't really need to get a job
I'm just gonna stay home and raise my
kids is what I'm gonna because I'm
getting by $1,000 a month eliminate
poverty which sounds good and Noble help
young couples start a family babe my
life is so expensive babe if we have
this baby it's gonna cost a lot of money
yeah but this plan is thousand dollars a
month babe we can have a baby oh my gosh
let's make a baby
awesome we can afford it now that's the
idea what can happen con
and the con is taxes would go up there'd
be a falling labor and there will be
another handout on top of all the other
handouts that we already have in America
which I'll explain to you how much
handout were given today so now some of
you are watching this and you're saying
Pat I think this is a great idea I think
ubi is genius and what makes you think
you are more qualified to say something
like this if if even Ilana some of these
other guys agree with this this is
genius we need to have something like
this what if all these robots take over
our jobs what if all this stuff happens
to us what am I gonna do this is not a
conversation about you bi this is a
conversation about a whole different
story
let me explain I want you to think about
a family the family's name is the Jones
family okay stay with me here this Jones
family's annual income is thirty six
thousand five hundred and forty dollars
that's their annual income but their
cost of living their expenses annually
are forty thousand nine forty that is
four thousand four hundred dollars more
than what they make every year so how do
they survive and on top of all this
stuff they have two hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars of debt I'm
talking credit card debt and on top of
that they have long term
of 1.5 four million dollars it's like
you're living in a house word 1.5 four
million dollars imagine your this family
you only make thirty six thousand
dollars your expenses are forty thousand
dollars a year you have two hundred
twenty thousand dollars of credit card
debt and you're living in a house that's
one point five four million dollars what
are you thinking about now I want you
think about this family your wife your
husband your kid comes and says hey mom
yeah what's up mom hey what's up son hey
hey Dad hey you you know baby I think we
need to go out there and buy this car
that is better than the current Chevy
Astro van that we have that's cheap and
it's used I think we need to go by this
new navigator came out in this new you
know expedition that came out or this
new Escalade that came out and your wife
says baby what are you talking about we
can't afford that wouldn't mean we can't
afford that but it's a great idea look
how amazing the car is babe we can't
afford it
babe that's not the way to think about
this we got to buy this car do you think
that is a good idea to go buy that
Escalade do you actually believe that
you really think that's a good idea
common-sense you're watching it's your
numbers person maybe does that make any
sense your wife your husband you go up
to your family would you say yes to it
everybody would say but we can't we have
1.5 million dollars to honor - what
about to go bankrupt we don't have any
kind of money what are you talking about
here well here's the reality of it this
is America this is not the Jones family
you just got at eight zeros to it let me
explain - what I mean by this that
annual income of $36,000 is really three
point six five four trillion dollars
that annual expenses of forty thousand
nine forty is really four trillion
dollars of expenses we are under four
hundred and forty billion dollars per
year okay that two hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars of debt our
national debt is twenty two point five
trillion dollars that's real money
twenty two point five trillion dollars
our long-term debt of one point five
four is really one hundred and fifty
four trillion dollars so you may be
asking Pat what is within that 154
trillion dollars what do you mean unpaid
commitments here's what we're talking
about Social Security we've committed we
got to pay for it there's a lot of
people that are depending on it Medicare
Part A which is Hospital Part B which is
medical and ND is your prescription fed
that held by public federal employees
and veteran benefits so that's 154
trillion dollars of unfunded liabilities
that we have to pay that's just the
commitment that we made to the people
right so that's gonna be happening but
the question I want you to be thinking
about is the following remember how I
said we make only thirty six thousand we
spent forty thousand watch how much
America spends on entitlement programs
out of our three point six five four
trillion dollars that comes in every
year 2.7 trillion dollars goes towards
entitlement programs let me unpack that
for you
988 billion dollars a year goes to
Social Security five hundred and eighty
nine billion goes to Medicare 600 four
billion dollars goes to Medicaid and
four hundred forty three billion dollars
goes to other welfare programs and for
some of you guys that were asking about
military military is six hundred and
eighty four billion dollars last year
that's six hundred eighty four billion
military 2.7 trillion dollars
entitlement programs and on top of that
andrew yang wants to spend three more
trillion dollars on top of our 2.7
trillion dollars of more entitlement
programs where Milton Friedman said
negative income tax let's get rid of all
these entitlement programs here's just
money back do whatever you want to do
with you want to get health and she just
want to get this it's on you it's on you
you decide what you want to do with that
we're not giving you any more
entitlement programs this is it he wants
to tag on top of everything else oh now
you're watching us you saying well Pat
why are so many people getting excited
about it you an idea like this if you
people are just like everybody seems
excited about it look if you think about
how the US government gets money is
typically three different ways one is
taxes one is borrow and money from other
cover governments and the other one is
printing money so let's talk about all
of them taxes if they raise taxes too
much Arthur Laffer once said if we go
above a thirty thirty four percent tax
rate and David Romer said the similar
thing who's out of Berkeley him and his
wife wrote a paper saying anything above
thirty four and a half percent
motivation goes that to create more
economy more Commerce right so if you
tax too much incentive goes away and
just like you incentivize your kids to
do something they got to incentivize us
adults to go do something and create
something better okay so the problem
with too much taxes and Center goes away
number two would borrow on money when
you borrow too much money you
into debt and other countries control
you Great Britain the money they
borrowed from us for World War two for
the weapons they bought they barely paid
off that money December 31st of 2006
think about how many years that was
until they paid it off right now they
had to make the decision but it took a
long time I we have a lot of money we
all right now
and last but not least is printing money
us can make a decisions at any point to
say we just are printing money but
here's a reality with printing money
I collect baseball cards a 1986 Michael
Jordan rookie card FLIR bgs nine and a
half which is Beckett graded services
nine and a half was so four seventy
seven thousand dollars a few years ago
okay seventy seven thousand dollars
fast-forward today that same seventy
seven thousand dollar car today Kim by
four eight nine thousand dollars let me
say that again that same seventy seven
thousand dollar car did he came by for
eight nine thousand dollars you know why
because back then there was only a
couple of them today there are hundreds
everywhere you can get a nine and a half
graded so people are called you know you
got one I'll give you seven grand I'll
give you eight Grau give you nine grant
it's now worth a lot anymore we can
print to be able to afford this five
point seven trillion dollars but dollar
goes down other countries control
America so there is ways to get money
but just because there's ways to get
money doesn't mean a family should go
out there and do it right so that's one
thing to be thinking about the second
thing I want you to think about is this
the fear of innovation you know but Pat
this is real Pat you mean to tell me
you're not concerned these are some
smart people saying this stuff but is
innovation really new like is this
really do is this something that we
ought to be that concern about did it
just that like did this just start
happening and robots are just coming out
have we had other kind of innovation
where experts were all worried about
what's gonna happen with the economy let
me give you a few examples of some cars
replace jobs I mean before a cars it was
horses right electricity replaced jobs
lights you know how you turn on the
lights lights replace jobs my dad used
to be able to make candles any run
that's how you made money candles don't
mean anything today except for a hot
date right
telephones replace jobs machines replace
jobs trains replace jobs calculators
replaced jobs computers replaced
jobs the internet replaced jobs video
games replay
based jobs so we can sit here and talk
about oh my gosh all these robots are
gonna be replacing that's called
innovation and advancements gonna be
taking place and every 30 to 50 years
jobs are going to be replaced this is
why 60% of Fortune 500 companies from
1970 are no longer around because it
replaces
and if you don't adapt if you don't
adjust and you don't pivot this is gonna
happen to everybody this isn't a new
thing so somebody may be watching the
same but Pat I know you're saying all
this stuff and this sounds good but man
I still think we have all the problems
we ought to be focused on our shouldn't
we kind of fix this kind of stuff here's
a reality but look your value system is
gonna tell you which problems you think
we should change and which problem you
think we should focus on and spend money
alright let me give you an example say
you and I are roommates and neither one
of us have a lot of money but every
month we set aside $100 of roommate
money that we say ok and we buy stuff
for the place that we look together all
of a sudden we have $400 saved and you
say I think we need to buy TV and I say
buddy we don't need a TV we can watch
the stuff on our phones we need a
microwave and we need like a George
Foreman grill to be able to cook and we
need a couple pants man we don't have
that are you kidding me man we got girls
coming we need a TV but we don't we need
to eat man we need a better Michael that
microbe is not working it's not even
doing a toaster stuff the decision on
who's right is based on the value system
party fun feed healthy you know all the
what is the one that you want to vote
for that's how we come out with programs
and you're generally gonna vote for a
program that's gonna be benefitting you
that's we all by the way this is not
just me or you this is everybody but we
have to sit there and say is that the
betterment for what we're really trying
to do to advance do we really go into
debt this kind of money and say yes to
ubi is it really that big of a concern
and the other thing I want you to think
about is the following look this isn't
the first time brilliant minds have set
things that aren't right a lot of people
say well Pat you again Elon Musk and
Zuckerberg said this listen I've said
stuff that I've been wrong a lot of
people have said stuff that are wrong
anybody that comes up and does something
big
it doesn't mean 100 percent of their
predictions are right let me share a few
with you
you ever heard of this guy named Bill
Gates you know Bill Gates from Microsoft
in 1981 this is what he said no one will
ever need more than 637 kilobytes of
memory for personal computer 640
kilobytes ought to be enough for anybody
Bill Gates said that it's a guy ward
nearly a hundred billion dollars or
something like that Thomas Edison in
1889 said fooling around with
alternative current which is AC is just
a waste of time no one will use it ever
Albert Einstein in 1932 said there's not
the slightest indication that nuclear
energy will ever be obtainable it would
mean that the atom would have to be
shattered at will
Einstein one of the biggest geniuses e
equals mc-squared something like that
Andy Grove was a genius somebody I
admired tremendously CEO of Intel in
1992 said the idea of a Personal
Communicator in every pocket is a pipe
dream by greed
this is Andy Grove saying this Steve
Jobs in oh three said the subscription
model of my music is bankrupt I think
you could make available the second
coming in a subscription model and it
might not be successful he said it's the
Rolling Stone magazine and last but not
least Charles dual commission or US
Patent 1890 and I said the following
everything that can be invented has
already been invented
can you imagine these are some genius
luminaries said the following things
you've said some things you were wrong
just because everybody said let's worry
about AI doesn't mean everybody's right
it just means it's an opinion as much as
we're worried about AI and robots and
all this other stuff I want you to think
about in a whole different way 20 years
ago could a seven-year-old
made 21 million dollars a year on
YouTube No
20 years ago would you and I have known
each other how how would you have known
me through youtube many of you around
the world 170 hundred 80 different
countries watched by a tainment how did
you find this
did I come and shake your hand have you
and I ever met before we probably never
met before how did this happen
technology Twitter you can share your
opinion facebook pictures I've got
family friends all over the world I can
see where they're at I don't need to
call them every five seconds to see
what's going on I can simply go on
Facebook and see the pictures of their
kids growing up I could have done that
before I would have missed these moments
so as much as we can put the fear
of what AI can do to people we got to
kind of look at it and say okay say this
happens one day it's not here today but
say it happens one day if we keep
watching movies with robots a it happens
in one day I best make sure I take care
of my family by making sure I adapt
adjust and pivot so if this ever comes
you're at least in good place
financially because if I go to sleep
every single night worrying about being
into the world kind of a life mi can
imagine if every day you worried about
what your wife is gonna do husband's
gonna do your kids are gonna do you're
constantly worried about what your job
is gonna do what the markets gonna do
I'm an insurance business can you
imagine if every day you worried about
dying what kind of a life is that it's
not the most likes it does a produce
offense it produced this it produces
fear people don't move on out like this
don't let a lot of these mines produce
the fear where you don't move my
encouragement to you is to listen to
this message and say you know what as
much as its advancing I'm gonna have
this thing work in my favor rather than
being a person that's frightened of it I
hope you do that so again I'm not
telling you anything I said today is
right or wrong I'm not saying what I
said these are my thoughts I'm not
telling you I'm 100 percent right what I
am encouraging you to do is the same
thing the next time you hear an idea
that sounds ludicrous or exciting rather
than jumping up excited or saying this
is terrible go do some research go
online and say yeah it's not as simple
as a guy made it out to be there's a
little bit deeper to this than that five
point seven trillion now we can't afford
that sounds good but we can't afford I
got it okay this is not this you got to
do your own due diligence to figure out
for yourself so again questions thoughts
comment below if you haven't subscribed
do so and I got another video I want you
to watch it's called minimum wage debunk
because it's another topic everyone's
talking about let's raise minimum wage
here's a video I did titled minimum wage
debunked again thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye